Racism isn't cute. Grow up. Man, up.
That I found it very embarrassing
[clears throat] that there was a bunch
of Muslim brothers sat next to us, by
the way,
watching the whole thing unfold and
didn't stand up to say anything.
Why do you guys feel that when you
immediately put on the niqab and hijab,
that means you're entitled to every
single man and safety of every single
man?
Piss off, bro.
Piss off.
Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this
brother of ours is facing. Just 10
minutes ago, he couldn't stand.
And alhamdulillah, through your
donations to Waqf Forever, today, not
only is he standing, but he has a smile
on his face. Jazakallah khair to each
and every one of you who dignified our
brother, our father
from Gaza.
Donate to Waqf Forever and help change
lives today.
A niqabi sister goes to Nando's with her
friend and her friend's child. And she's
sitting there, and this is what occurs.
Who is to blame? We're going to come to
that in a minute. Let's watch the video
for ourselves and see what actually
happened. And there were Muslim men
sitting around there, apparently, and
seeing what's unfolding. Was it her
fault that she was in a free-mixing
environment, uh coming out by herself,
where was the mahram, or do we blame the
men who were sitting there doing
nothing? Let's watch the video for
context and then be ready for some
grilling, cuz this really, really got me
angry. Racism isn't cute. Grow up. Man,
up. Man, up.
Man, up.
You are racist. I can hear everything
you guys have been saying since the
moment you got here. And then throwing
food at my FRIEND AND MY CHILD NEXT TO
ME. I'm Why are you not You weren't
expecting anybody to say anything to
you. Grow up.
I never done that. I never done that.
How old are you? You're like
He's 16, 17.
Sorry about it. I've just spoke to them.
Apologies. They're just young kids. It's
unbelievable. I was We were patient from
the beginning, but he started throwing
food. I told you all um
That is the context. Then we're going to
go to the video of the sister further
clarifying. Then we're going to watch a
video of some Bengali guy That's the
name, Bengali something, whatever his
name is. Okay. Um uh blaming the sister.
I mean, brothers and sisters, let me be
honest with you, okay? Sister, why are
you out with your non-mahram? Why are
you in a free-mixing environment? You
wish I said that.
Yeah, you wish. Oh, he was coming, "Oh,
yeah, these dawah bros." Shut up. Shut
up.
Guys,
I'm going to watch this video. Before I
watch this video, there's context, okay?
Muslim men, you guys I wish I could use
the foul language cuz I know what you
word I would use for you cowards. If
that was my wife in any restaurant,
being harassed These are little kids,
okay, no problem, whatever for that
matter, even though they're wrong.
Alhamdulillah, yeah? And they've been
called out and their parents have
apologized to the sister.
If if my wife was in that situation and
I sped up and came there
and these guys were there or not there.
If they were little kids, okay. There's
a different verbally dealing with them.
They're little children, I'm not going
to to get physical with little kids.
But wallahi, let me tell you something.
If they were grown men and they were
Muslim men sitting and doing nothing,
wallahi, I don't know if I would throw
punches at the ones who were abusing my
wife or start throwing punches on the
Muslim men who were watching there like
a coward, okay? This is so key. Muslim
men, you guys have become absolute
cowards. Yes, you're coward.
And I know you might be coming talking
about, "Yo, it's the estrogen in my
water that I drink whatever." I don't
care whatever it is, bro. You can get
out your backside and do something about
it. Because the fact that you are there
sitting, I don't know. Look, I imagine
myself in that Nando's
sitting there and a sister Should I tell
you something? Wallahi, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is my witness. Even these
radical feminists and [__] that I
hate them for the sake of Allah, nothing
personal, yeah, who are trying to
mislead mislead the youth, wallahi, if I
saw any of them being harassed by
anyone,
not for them, for the sake of Allah
and for the izza of the Muslims, yes,
and Islam, brother,
I would go there and fight if needed be.
Why? Because it's for the sake of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. I don't need a
cookie or anything from them.
Thank you very much.
But, to sit there and know that another
sister who wears a niqab, who's spoken
about being abused before, alcohol being
thrown at her, and said that there were
Muslim men still watching that, what
kind of cowardly behavior is that? And
it gets worse. Now, we've got this guy,
I'm going to try my best to use my tone
in a calm manner because I'm really,
really angry. He's a Muslim. Look what
he goes, and he's basically trying to
blame the sister. And I'm like
bamboozled. I'm like, yo.
And I'm seeing brothers are coming out
on TikTok and saying, "Yo."
And I'm like, bro, is this actually Is
there actually Muslim men
who are blaming the sister
for coming out? Are you Are you stupid?
Wallahi.
She wears a niqab. She gets harassed. My
wife, sometimes it's said, you know,
people looking at her in a
certain way. That makes me angry. Let
alone hearing That's why I tell her to
be home in a certain at a certain time.
Be careful, you know, etc.
When she's around, be vigilant, yeah?
Let alone being abused. Do you know how
hard it is to wear the niqab? Do you
know how hard it is to wear the hijab?
They are
Look, they, from the the way they look,
they they can be seen as Muslim. Bro, I
can look like a hippie. They can say,
"Look, I don't know if he's a Muslim or
not." Yes? I have a beard. Kuffar men
have beards. But, you don't see
non-Muslim women wear the hijab. It's
damn difficult. Let's be honest. It is
difficult, and they're doing a great job
by representing that against all odds
with these brothers who criticize them
anyways for wearing a pink hijab. This
guy got me really angry. Let's watch it
for ourselves, inshallah. of this video,
one of them being how I mentioned that I
found it very embarrassing that there
was a bunch of Muslim brothers sat next
to us, by the way,
watching the whole thing unfold and
didn't stand up to say anything. Now,
even though I do find it very
embarrassing, it is not a shock. This
has happened to me many times. I was in
West London once, which is a very Muslim
populated area.
And I've had a man throw alcohol on me,
specifically on my niqab, which is on my
face, near my mouth. So, imagine the
panic I felt.
And there was Muslim men
wearing a thobe, which they are
evidently Muslims. So, if you're going
to dress like that, you need to act the
part.
Um
they were breaking their necks to see
what was going on, but didn't think to
stand up and say anything.
>> You guys might think, in context, "Hey,
there's absolutely nothing that would be
wrong with her video, right? You know,
she was a Muslim woman that was visibly
harassed by people, you know, and you
know, people should stand up for her
because this is clear Islamophobia."
Well, let me actually tell you guys, in
context, what happened.
She started a fight with a bunch of
little kids at a restaurant.
>> Bro, what the hell are you talking
about, bro? Bro, wallahi, I I I I'm
holding myself back not to cuss you out.
What do you mean? Who are you to know
the context, bro? She made a video
explaining what happened.
And the parents of the kids got in
contact and to apologize to her. The
manager said they were wrong. Some One
of their friends came and apologized.
Brother, after what sisters with the
niqab and hijab are going through, yes,
with the hardship of wearing the hijab
and niqab, let alone let alone we have
certain people in in in in in uh Muslim
men who already making it harder, you
know, if you wear this and uh
criticizing unnecessarily, not justly,
unnecessarily, yes, or you wear pink
hijab or one single hair strand is
showing up. Okay, uh yes. And the same
men, by the way, the same men who
criticize that, probably see a nun those
and not do nothing. Okay, let's carry
on. So, how do you know what happened
for you to come and say, "Oh, there's a
context." Why would she pick on
children, bro? What the flipping hell
are you talking about? Why are you
making it hard on your brothers and
sisters, on your sisters specifically?
So, I actually watched this entire
video. You guys can even read the
caption. Listen, I'm not condoning
Islamophobia,
harassing Muslim women, or even saying
what happened to her was justified. But,
what I am saying is that why are you
picking a fight with a bunch of little
kids acting stupid? If you are a Muslim
woman wearing niqab and someone's
throwing food at you,
What are you talking about, man? Are you
Are you in her shoes or any woman's
shoes? Imagine you are being picked on
regularly because of the way you dress,
people looking at, etc.
Anything small will trigger you because
you are fed up of abuse. So, it's easy
for you to talk cuz you don't wear the
niqab. You don't wear the hijab, habibi.
Yes, it's easy. If anything, someone say
you are You look like a emo. You know
those people the What they called?
These These You know the the um
They like they dress up dark and
>> They emo?
>> Yeah. They got dark clothes. Yeah, like
these goth-looking people. Somebody come
and say, "You don't have to deal with
that." So, it's for you to belittle the
experience to be like, "Oh, it's just
some little kids, etc." It's It's To me,
you're nitpicking. I got I got to
imagine what she did and leave. And this
entire argument, "Oh, it's Muslim men's
fault. It's Muslim men's fault. It's
Muslim men's fault." Why do you feel
like since you wear the niqab or wear
the hijab? May Allah bless you for
wearing the niqab, by the way, right?
May Allah bless every Muslim woman who
wears hijab and niqab, by the way. Why
do you guys feel that when you
immediately put on the niqab and hijab,
that means you're entitled to every
single man and safety of every single
man? As Muslim men, we have in first
nature an obligation to protect the
women in our family, right? Our wives,
our sisters, our nieces, our mothers,
our grandmothers, our aunts. Random
Muslim woman in wearing a niqab starting
fight with a bunch of kids is not a
first-hand nature where Muslim men need
to step up, get up from their chair, and
start saying something. Well, I just
want to I should be honest with you. I
swear the least I can say is
you're a coward.
The least I can say to you, brother, is
you are a coward. Are you telling me
your woman folk is going to be sat in
Nando's in a restaurant being harassed.
I don't give a [__] if it's a
13-year-old, 14-year-old, 15-year-old,
16-year-old, grandpa, man, I don't care.
And I'm just going to be like, "Yo, it's
not my duty." Bro, where's the Where is
your evidence from Islam? Bring me
evidence from the Quran and the Sunnah,
bro, that when you see anyone being
harassed, brother, that can be
non-Muslim woman, you're just going to
sit there as a Muslim man when we are
told the lowest form of iman is to move
a harmful object from the road road.
Road lowest. Yes, the Prophet said he
said, "If you see evil, stop it with
your hand." Yeah, um
uh stop it with your hand. If you cannot
um stop it with your tongue, and if you
cannot hate it in your heart, okay? Now,
there's explanations to that, etc., but
you cannot come and tell me that your
woman I'm going to go "It's not my
mahram." What are you talking about,
bro? Are you Are you What like are you
Bro, are you okay? Like, are you
genuinely psychologically okay? You're
telling me that I'm going to see a woman
folk. Bro, wallahi, if you came and saw
your woman folk being attacked, and I'm
as a Muslim man sitting there having my
flipping chicken, yes, uh chicken,
whatever it is that I'm having, okay? Uh
got estrogen running through my blood.
I'm a little flipping feminine little
Anyways, yeah? And you're going to come
and say, "Bro, what kind of a man are
you?" You're not going to come and tell
me that you're going to watch You're
going to be happy with a Muslim man
standing there watching your family.
Dude, you belittle wallahi it makes me
so angry. And I think you're the only
person who's um come out with this
nonsense, okay? We as Muslim men, it is
our amana and our duty. Yes, we are
ready to put our life on the line
for anyone. Yes? Why? Because that's
what our religion teaches us. We are
taught to be like that. Yes? Okay? Learn
martial arts. Go out there and learn to
defend yourself, okay? Whatever it is.
I'm not trying to act like a hero here,
but I'm really annoyed that some Muslim
men, sadly like these individuals, who
are coming and
blaming her.
Blaming her. That is disgusting and
disgraceful. And I will call out anyone.
And you know what? Subhanallah, the at
the time of the Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him, yes?
Banu Qaynuqa, yes? They
tied a woman's hijab when she walked
off.
You know her awrah was shown or
something like that. Brother, people
died.
Brother, people died because of that,
yeah? Are you mad? You're going to come
to a Muslim woman and do that? Brother,
people died that day.
Yeah? Because a Muslim man didn't come
and say, "Oh, that's not my mahram. Oh,
that's that kind of bull crap kind of
kind of." He said, "No, you mad." Yes?
They would have done No, only that,
subhanallah. This is a story. A Roman
Byzantine soldier imprisoned a Muslim
woman who then cried out, "Oh,
Mu'tasim." When the caliph was told of
this, he immediately mobilized an and an
army and sent a message to the Byzantine
ruler saying, "For the caliph
Al-Mu'tasim
Mu'tasim Billah to the Roman Empire, I
will send an army that the front will
reach you and the end will be here."
He didn't come and say, "Oh, you know,
it's not it's not my mahram." Brother,
he mobilized an army.
Yes? And believe me, there were women to
be defended. Even though I can say today
with these munafiqis, I'm not blaming at
all. I'm not blaming at all. Yes? You
know? Even then,
are they a Muslim woman? Are they a
woman? Let me put it like this, forget
that because most of the munafiqis are
kuffar. Most of them are disbelievers,
man. Even then,
is it a woman? If it's a woman or a
child or even an innocent man,
yes?
It is our job as Muslims to stand up.
So, my son told me a story. I was at my
dad's table. I went to go eat in Shaa's.
I'm in the rest I'm in I'm in the I had
my food. The guy was taking my order.
There was a clown who was keep abusing
the
the the guy was serving food. "Hurry up.
This, that." And I didn't say anything.
I said, "You know what? Okay, whatever."
I didn't want to get involved, etc. Do
you get what I'm trying to say?
And then he would start picking on the
guy. "Oh, put the salad faster. Do the
salad." Brother, I lost my cool. And
there were some two hijabi sisters and a
brother there, yeah?
I said, "Brother, what's your problem?
Why you keep picking on him, man? Huh?
Shut your mouth. I told him, 'Shut your
mouth, bro. Shut up.'" Why?
Bro, he's doing his job, providing for
his family. Who are you to abuse him
because you are in a rush? Yeah?
Piss off, bro.
Piss off.
This is the attitude, and that's the
reason why we as Muslim men, we should
not make it harder for our sisters.
Yeah? And I'm sorry I'm going on a rant,
but wallahi, this attitude is
disgusting. And I've to be consistent
here.
It also applies to our sisters. How many
times have brothers been violated?
Aki Ayman, yes? Him and his wife being
mocked by some flipping Her name is
that, by the way. Yeah? That's her name,
by the way. Okay? Some girl, yes? Uh I
don't want to mention, yes?
Mocking him and his wife, bringing the
family into it. How many of you
TikTokers, how many of you female
TikTokers who when I mentioned
somebody's eyelashes, all the hell BROKE
LOOSE. HOW DARE YOU? EYELASHES, which I
apologize to you, and I was wrong. True.
You lost the plot.
But when a man is accused of zina,
accusing Aki Ayman of zina,
insulting his wife indirectly, whatever
it is for that matter,
not a single one. So, let's be
consistent here.
Why is it when when
a honor of a Muslim man or a woman,
but you sisters go quiet.
And brothers, even if they do, two
wrongs don't make a right. I'm saying
from our side, we should always do that.
I'm just saying, my dear sisters,
be consistent. Just the way it hurts you
when you are there being oppressed, and
these coward Muslim men, I don't know
who they are. I wish I know who the face
are. Yeah, I didn't do nothing.
Imagine Muslim brothers in the dawa
scene or outside of the dawa scene, yes?
Whose families are brought into and
slander is made against them,
and you guys go quiet.
Let's be consistent. I'm sorry for
ranting, but I had to get off my chest.
So, shame on this guy and those Muslim
men who watched this sister get there.
Sadly, subhanallah, we are in the wrong
place at the wrong time. I wish we was
brothers were there. I know many
brothers out there who would have dealt
with this in a different way. They're
kids anyways, but you know, in these
situations, make sure you defend your
sisters. Make sure wherever they are,
wallahi, I don't care if she's a
five-star grade A kafir who's a
feminist.
If she, in front of me or any brother,
is being wronged by someone else, step
up.
Two wrongs don't make a right. You step
up and do it for the sake of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. May Allah protect us
from being cowardly, because there is
hadith that talks about how Allah
doesn't like men who are cowardly and
stingy. Okay, may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala protect us from that and do some
martial arts. Yes? Are you You guys
might know about my condition with
eyesight, yeah? Okay, my eyesight is
deteriorating and subhanallah, I can't
do boxing because of that. Yeah? Now,
I've gone to Brazilian jiu-jitsu because
I don't want a day that comes that I
cannot protect my family. Yes?
If my with my eyes, you know, I can't
swing whatever, at least I can choke.
Inshallah. So, please guys,
just a reminder from me to you guys.
Sorry for venting out. I found it very
disturbing that there are men out there
blaming sisters for this.
Woah, I feel better now. [sighs]
It's actually interesting, you know, I
think talking is therapy. You know?
That's why I think it makes sense, you
know, sometimes my wife just vents out
and I'm just like, you know what? It's
actually fantastic. Now, I understand my
wife. It's It's actually fantastic.
Sometimes you need to vent out.
Sometimes you have to vent out. I feel I
feel much better, alhamdulillah.
Thank you, Abdul Kareem. You spoke the
truth. Till next time, brothers and
sisters, assalamualaikum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh. Please make dua for
brother Abdul Kareem to find the wife.
He's a fantastic, handsome man.
Mashallah, make dua for him. He's
looking for a sister. I got to get this
call, inshallah.